so recently i watched this documentary
called social dilemma which is about
getting addicted to your phone getting
addicted to all these apps
and they had all these different
executives from twitter
and the person who created the like
button and facebook and pinterest and
they were all talking about oh my gosh
i'm addicted to my email i'm addicted to
facebook i'm addicted to this and you
got to be careful
and they did a phenomenal job portraying
these three guys that are behind and
this one kid that the mom
creates a bed and says if you can keep
your phone
away for one weekend you don't touch it
i'm gonna go out there and buy you a
brand new phone because you broke it so
the son puts it over there and they lock
it and the daughter couldn't do it she
breaks it takes the phone out because
she has to look at what's going on for
the phone
so one day he's okay without the phone
second day he's okay without the phone
the third day he sees a girl saying
something that he likes
then he looks at the phone takes it he
can't last for one week he lasts for two
days
and the whole messaging is we got to be
careful to not let our kids get addicted
to phones and then at the end they make
all these recommendations what to do
at what age what is you give them the
phones you shouldn't start till 16.
very very good documentary for anybody
and everybody to watch
having said that when i watched the
documentary
to me it was kind of like you have to be
careful because these social media
platforms don't care who you are so you
can do a search for
you know a certain search for climate
change
on the west coast because they're mostly
liberal and so climate change
is real it's the biggest threat to the
world
and then you can do climate change in
midwest with a lot of conservatives
climate change is a hoax because that's
what you want to hear and you can do
climate change in east coast because
it's a lot of liberals
climate change is real and so they're
manipulating their audience right and
they shouldn't be doing all this other
stuff etc etc
fine um i'm with that just so everybody
knows you know what my position is when
it comes down to
you know twitter and censoring and you
can't say this and you can't say this
and youtube and google and all this
stuff
they're independent businesses i spoke
spoke to my very good friends prager
dennis and sue and they went through
soon youtube because of prager
university and i saw what happened with
them and
how yes you have freedom of speech from
america but not necessarily companies
they can do whatever they want to do
with you
uh if they want to censor you or not but
you can't work as a platform because so
it's very complex
long story short they can censor if they
want to and they're doing it right
however let's talk about this isn't the
whole purpose
of any business for you to get addicted
to their product
let me ask that question one more time
isn't the purpose of
any business for you to get addicted to
their product
what do you mean by that pat i can't
stand fantasy football
because fantasy football i have friends
who spend 30 hours a week on fantasy
football
my draft my guy's injured oh my god let
me get on this side the whole purpose of
fantasy football is for you to get
addicted to it just so you know that's
the business model
i got friends here in the office for 10
years i ran a sales office without ever
having
any coffee machines you know why weird
reason it's my weird
you know quirk or whatever you want to
call it i don't like stains on carpets
so i never had a coffee in my coffee in
my sales office
ten years we had our guys would stand
outside to drink the coffee machine
but i got guys on my sales organization
17 000 people in our company our
insurance agents
drinking coffee some drink four five six
a day
some go to starbucks two three times a
day great job to starbucks for creating
a market and getting people to be
addicted to coffee
it's addicting ain't it okay cigarettes
philip morris what do they do
they created a business model and put
something in the nicotine for you to get
addicted to it
look what kind of an empire they created
they even created a movie about it and
they created guys going around getting
people to say it's not a big deal if you
smoke cigarettes not going to kill you
and you have to finally put that sign on
the side
smoking cigarettes can kill you from
cancer but the business model is for you
to get addicted to what
cigarettes what does mcdonald's do what
do you think ronald mcdonald was about
do you think it was for adults or do you
think it's built for kids to get
addicted
to say mom dad i want to go to
mcdonald's why because ronald mcdonald's
going to be there
what's the happy meal about to get you
and i to go there no it's to get people
to get addicted to go there for
because of kids what's a radio's
business model for you to get addicted
to it so you can listen to 24 7
so you can sell more advertising what's
tv's business model
for you to get addicted to a tv show so
for that 23 minutes that you're watching
to get seven minutes of advertising
those seven minutes they can convert you
to buy whatever the product may be
philip morris a drug
a you know new this or a new car
whatever it is to get your attention
what's the business model of any sports
to create a leaders bulletin with a lot
of stats
and brackets and a lot of competition
and fights and controversy and media
for you to watch sports how much do you
consume sports
espn fox all this other stuff just so
everybody knows that they're watching
this
the social dilemma documentary is right
but here's the point it's not on the
producer
of how they create the product this
whole thing
is about marketing yes they're using
algorithms all this other stuff
but it's very easy to say well it's
dangerous we got to be careful with our
kids yeah i don't i don't disagree
but that's the responsibility of a
parent
on the set of standards they create for
their kids that's not the responsibility
of the product creator
i don't blame facebook or twitter or
instagram i produce it on the person
that's allowing their kids to get
addicted to it
i'm going to sit there and blame the
other guys how long have drugs and
alcohol been around
there was a time i drank a ball of
tequila every week when i was in the
army
every week i was drinking tequila every
week for
two years straight when i was in the
army i partied every single week and
what i do
boom tequila hey what's up contest who
can drink the most all this
crazy stuff you do when you're in the
army if you've been a military you kind
of know what i'm talking about
it's on the consumer see i want
i want to fix this if i can fix this
then i can be careful about having an
addictive personality because i have one
i don't want to get addicted to a lot of
new things i got to control this
it's a great documentary it can make you
think about a lot of other stuff kids
hey uh dad can i watch the phone no
everybody else is doing it
i'm not everybody else i wish somebody
else was my daddy
you want to go to live in this house go
ahead no i was just kidding okay cool
you're a bad david
let's figure this thing out you want to
play some legos let's play some legos
you want to go ride a bike together
let's go ride your bike do you want to
go swim let's go
you want to play basketball let's go
play basketball what do you want to do
let's go watch them let's go watch a
movie no problem
we got to control ourselves from getting
addicted to a lot of these other things
that is on us so as much as i love the
documentary that's being out there
if you allow this to get you addicted to
it
that's on you it's the job of a
smartphone to do that
it's the job of an app to do that it's
the job of facebook to do that
it's the job of twitter to do that it's
the job of instagram to do that
we can't blame the drug
we can't blame the drug dealer we have
to look at there and look at the user
drug dealers are going to be around
forever were you ever approached by
drugs
i was approached by it all the time
spending more time
talking to our kids and to ourselves
about what things we get addicted to
and spend less time trying to blame
these other guys yes they need to be
held accountable yes facebook amazon all
these guys need to be held accountable
on certain things they're doing selling
our info on the back end those things
privacy yes 100
we have to be able to do that kind of
stuff but we can't just point fingers at
companies saying
they're addicting every business model
is built
for you to somehow get addicted to it
and those who are very successful guess
what
they did a better job at everybody else
all the major channels in america that
are killing it
they're the best channels all the major
networks they're the best channels
because they got people to get addicted
to their news
having said that rather than spending
time blaming all the things that people
are getting addicted to
why not work on better strategies to
make sure you and i don't get addicted
to it
spend time talking to your kids about it
your spouse about it your family about
it the people in your office about it
and see what happens and if you got a
business model or company you're running
that other people aren't addicted to
maybe you got to do something about
making your business
a little bit more addicting maybe you
got to do something about people wanting
your product more than just once
that is a business model so maybe this
is a crazy message you don't want to
hear
and it gets you to think about a whole
different way but there's going to be
more
addicting products that are going to
come for a long
time this is never going
to stop so now get a sheet of paper out
and write down on a sheet of paper
what are some addictions you have that
no one else knows about games
video games porn you know twitter
facebook youtube what is it fantasy
football what is it
how much is it taking away from you what
can you do to minimize it
and if you put that time elsewhere what
will it do for you having said that i
want to give you a throwback video from
five years ago titled 16
time wasters if you've never seen that
click over here
to go watch that video and on top of
that have a great week everybody bye
you